bahin has accused Yemen's houthis of
killing two of its soldiers in a drone
strike near the Saudi border bahin is
part of the Saudi Le Coalition that has
fought the houthi since 2015 Saudi
Arabia is calling Monday's incident a
provocation and is threatening to
respond a houi spokesman says the Saudi
lead Coalition has killed several Yemen
soldiers in the past month and calls the
violations
regrettable last week Saudi and houi
officials held a round of talks and rad
on a potential agreement to end the
conflict in Yemen Saudi Arabia said some
progress was made during the meetings
but gave no further
details well Al jaer hasham ALB is here
for more context on this story and just
how significant is this attack and and
if the houthis are indeed behind it what
message do you think that they are
trying to send here so the houthis do
control that entire areas bordering
Saudi Arabia from the north Sada is the
the focal point and the stronghold of
the huis in the northern part of Yemen
still they have not issued any statement
on this particular incident and there's
no claim of responsibility from the hois
is it a setback it's a major setback
particularly against the backdrop of
what you've been talking about which is
basically the talks between the huis and
the Saudis about a permanent political
Su solution that would put an end to the
fighting between the
two if there are divisions within the
the houthis this doesn't particularly
bow well for a settlement to any
conflict does it I personally I was
there in mid July I don't think there is
a division within the establishment
itself it's a very well organized
militarily and politically institution
they do have an absolute say and they do
have a leader who has massive control
over the military establishment and the
political institutions of the
country what kind of impact would it
have on the future if the sist decide to
ret at launching uh attacks against the
hthis it will lead to an unprecedented
wave and cycle of Confrontation between
the Saudis and the huis in a level that
we haven't seen before yeah How likely
do you think that that could happen
Crown Prince Muhammad B Salman of Saudi
Arabia insisted he wants to move forward
when it comes to the deal with the with
with with this with the with the huis
and I do understand from my own sources
that they are so close to final
finalizing the deal the Hui still insist
they want
the Saudis to compensate them to pay
wages of the public servants and also
they to open to uh reopen the ports
which are under the control of the hthis
and the airport of s also they say we
want a time frame for all the foreign
troops to withdraw from Yemen including
the southern part of the of Yemen which
is not controlled by the huis but which
is also controlled by different Regional
forces the Saudis and the
amerities I mean even it's been over a
year since the ceasefire negotiations
began I mean even before this attack why
did they stall what was the sticking
point there was a moment when Saudi
Arabia said the moment we will finalize
the deal we will try to mediate a
political settlement between all the
different factions let me just give an
idea to our viewers what what is
happening in Yemen there is not one
entity in Yemen there is a North
controlled by the huis there is a South
controlled by The secessionists Who want
to restore uh Marxist list state that
existed before
1994 when the both United North and 1990
when both North and South United there
are different forces operating on the
ground Saudis have a huge leverage over
the internationally recognized
government the Emirates have a huge
leverage over the secessionist in the
South the huis are saying no we sign a
deal you have to pull out from the
country by the way today we marked 61
years since uh military soldiers
launched a crew in the northern part of
the country against the Imam which was
one of the oldest dynasties in in
northern part of Yemen it just gives you
an idea about how this country has been
always divided and struggling to come to
move forward oh thank you so much we
really do appreciate you coming in and
breaking it all down for us it's uh elj
Hashim Al thank you